This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. There's no shortcut for saving time, but saving money is simple. Just combine your car and home insurance with Bel Air Direct and save. Get a quote at bellair direct.com. Hello, everybody. I'm Gemma Spike, and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through the biggest changes, moments and transitions of our 20s,
这是一个IHeart播客。保证真实。节省时间没有捷径，但省钱很简单。只需将您的汽车和房屋保险与Bel Air Direct合并即可省钱。请访问belairdirect.com获取报价。大家好。我是Gemma Spike，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，这是一个我们探讨二十多岁时最大的变化、时刻和转变的播客，
and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody, welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. Thank you for joining me today. I have more of a chatty episode for you than we usually do. I kind of just wanted to share chat, muse over something I've been psychoanalyzing a lot in myself recently, just to see if any of you relate and see if any of you feel the same way. And that is my relationship with ambition. and how that is changing as I enter my late 20s, as long as I can remember. And as long as I have been, I guess, a person with a personality and a memory, I have been an ambitious person. And what I mean by ambitious is that I think I've been somebody who wanted lots from life and who was really okay with the hard work that it might take to get there. And even when I was a kid, you know, I don't think people,
以及它们对我们心理意味着什么的节目。大家好，欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。感谢您今天加入我。这一期节目比我们平时做的更像是一次闲聊。我只是想分享、交流、沉思一些我最近在自我分析中思考很多的事情，看看你们是否也有共鸣，看看你们是否也有同样的感受。那就是我与野心的关系，以及随着我进入二十多岁后期，这种关系是如何改变的。只要我记事起，或者说只要我是一个有性格、有记忆的人，我一直都是一个有野心的人。我所说的有野心，是指我认为我是一个对生活有很多追求，并且非常愿意为实现这些目标而付出艰苦努力的人。即使在我小时候，你知道，我不认为人们，
would have used the word ambitious, but they certainly used words like that were pretty similar. You know, I think people would have described me as very stubborn and enthusiastic and maybe a perfectionist and goal-driven. I think even to this day, it's how my friends would describe me. I'm pretty sure everybody I've ever dated would say that I am ambitious for better or for worse. And I certainly know that it's something that my parents feel particularly proud of, that they've kind of, you know, cultivated in me since I was a kid. I think ambition alongside a good dose of luck has definitely gotten me a lot in my life so far. You know, I've written a book and it's a podcast that you are literally listening to is on Netflix and, you know, I'm not going to go on and on about,
会用“有野心”这个词，但他们肯定会用一些非常相似的词。你知道，我认为人们会形容我非常固执、热情，也许还是个完美主义者和目标导向型的人。我想即使到了今天，我的朋友们也会这样形容我。我很确定我交往过的每一个人都会说，无论好坏，我都是一个有野心的人。我当然知道，这是我父母特别引以为豪的一点，因为从我小时候起，他们就在我身上培养了这种特质。我认为野心加上一点点运气，确实让我在生活中得到了很多。你知道，我写过一本书，而你现在正在听的这个播客也在Netflix上，而且，你知道，我不想没完没了地谈论，
oh, my God, everything that I've achieved and, oh, all these things, because that feels very arrogant. But I do think that I've taken for granted or as a given that if I want something in life, I really don't find it that difficult to work hard for it and to be a little bit delusional about my ability to get it. What I've come to realize, though, is the cost of that trait and how the only thing that ambition really gives you after a while is just more ambition and a greater fear of inadequacy or a greater fear that you are not living up to your own expectations. and I think it creates this void that just at some stage cannot be filled by any more accomplishments. And it also comes with the cost that is more than just work. You know, your
天哪，我取得的一切成就，以及所有这些事情，因为那感觉非常傲慢。但我确实认为，我把如果我在生活中想要什么，我就真的不觉得为之努力工作并对自己获得它的能力有一点点妄想是困难的这件事，当作了理所当然。然而，我意识到的是这种特质的代价，以及野心在一段时间后真正能给你的，仅仅是更多的野心，以及对不足的更大恐惧，或者对你没有达到自己期望的更大恐惧。我认为这创造了一个在某个阶段无法被更多成就填补的空虚。而且它还伴随着不仅仅是工作的代价。你知道，你的
relationship suffer, your sense of personality kind of disappears. You feel very guilty about not being productive. And I think if we're being honest, it kind of just cannibalizes all other aspects of your life and all other aspects of who you are until it is the only thing that you are. I think it's very hard and it gets very hard to know who you are beyond your ambition or beyond your productivity, the more you lean into it and the more that you kind of see it is the greatest thing that you have to offer the world or yourself. So I want to talk about it today. I want to talk about how I've come to the realization that my ambition might not be the friend that I thought it was, how we can discover who we are within.
人际关系会受损，你的个性感会消失。你会因为没有产出而感到非常内疚。而且我认为如果我们诚实的话，它几乎吞噬了你生活的其他方面和你作为人的其他方面，直到它成为你唯一的特质。我认为很难，而且越来越难知道除了你的野心或产出之外你是谁，你越是沉溺于它，越是把它视为你对世界或对自己所能提供的最伟大的东西。所以我今天想谈谈它。我想谈谈我是如何意识到我的野心可能并不是我以为的那种朋友，我们如何才能发现我们在野心之外的自我，以及我们是如何从一开始就陷入这种成就情结的。
out our ambition and just how we get wrapped up in this accomplishment complex to begin with. And I don't know, yeah, how are we going to get out of it together, you and I? So I'm very excited for this episode. It's a personal one. I hope you enjoy it. Without further ado, let's get into the complicated psychology of ambition. So I want to begin with kind of talking about how my own relationship with ambitial. has developed over time from when I was a child to a teenager to now being an adult because I do
我不知道，是的，你和我将如何一起摆脱它？所以我对这一期节目感到非常兴奋。这是一个非常私人的话题。希望你喜欢。废话少说，让我们进入野心的复杂心理学。所以我想从谈论我自己的野心关系是如何随着时间的推移，从我小时候到青少年，再到现在的成年而发展的开始，因为我确实
think that it's a familiar and fairly relatable story, particularly if you yourself were a high achiever as a kid or you are the eldest child, the eldest daughter in your family or you came from a particular kind of family where there was a real message of accomplishment. something to know about ambition and how it's spoken about specifically in psychology is that ambition is seen as a personality trait that is distinctly human. Other mammals and other animals, like they may want power, they may want control or leadership or resources, but no other creature wants the kind of success that humans seem to want, which is more than just resources and more than just being seen a certain way
认为这是一个熟悉且相当容易引起共鸣的故事，特别是如果你自己小时候就是一个高成就者，或者你是家里的长子、长女，或者你来自一个真正强调成就的特定家庭。关于野心以及它在心理学中是如何被谈论的，有一点需要知道，那就是野心被视为一种独特的人类人格特质。其他哺乳动物和其他动物，它们可能想要权力、控制、领导地位或资源，但没有其他生物想要人类似乎想要的那种成功，那不仅仅是资源，也不仅仅是被他人以某种方式看待，
by others. It's more than reputational concerns. It's really a sense of achievement and it's a sense of personal pride in something. And I think ambition links back to our human search for meaning and our desire to feel important and like we matter. And I just don't think that that's something that other animals seem to be preoccupied by. Particularly, I think with ambition, there is this sense that, you know, if I achieve this thing and I get this and I make this, and I make something of myself and I make something that I'm proud of, then I will be important and I will matter and my life will have some purpose that others can recognize and therefore it will feel more valid. So it gets very philosophical very quickly. Ambition in psychology as well is also different to
不仅仅是声誉问题。它确实是一种成就感，是对某件事的个人自豪感。我认为野心与我们人类对意义的追求以及我们想要感到重要、想要感到我们有价值的渴望联系在一起。我只是不认为这是其他动物似乎会关注的事情。特别是，我认为对于野心，有一种感觉，你知道，如果我实现了这件事，我得到了这个，我创造了这个，我成就了自我，我创造了一些我引以为豪的东西，那么我就会变得重要，我就会有价值，我的生活就会有他人可以认可的某种目的，因此它会感觉更有效。所以它很快就会变得非常哲学化。心理学中的野心也不同于
aspiration. And I really think that this is important to know because aspiration on its own is and wanting something bigger than yourself or wanting a specific goal or to realize a dream that is often quite healthy. And it's a singular kind of thing. And it's just for you and provide structure and purpose. Ambition is this pervasive trait or way of being or seeing the world that literally has no end. There is no final goal. There is no final moment of satisfaction. The task of ambition is never accomplished. And I think the prize is always out of reach. and that is what makes it so kind of mentally difficult at times. In some cultures, I think ambition is very synonymous as well with greed. And it gets a bad reputation. It's somewhat seen as a vice.
抱负。我真的认为了解这一点很重要，因为抱负本身就是想要比自己更大的东西，或者想要一个特定的目标，或者实现一个梦想，这通常是相当健康的。它是一种单一的东西。它只是为了你，并提供结构和目的。野心是一种无处不在的特质，或者是一种存在方式，或者是一种看待世界的方式，它实际上没有终点。没有最终的目标。没有最终的满足时刻。野心的任务永远无法完成。而且我认为奖品总是遥不可及的，这就是为什么它有时在心理上如此困难。在某些文化中，我认为野心也与贪婪非常同义。它名声不好。它在某种程度上被视为一种恶习。
It's seen as an evil. And I really think the older I've gotten, the more I get that. Ambition can really turn people into someone that they're not. It can cause us to really disregard others. I feel like I've seen it, you've seen it. And there is no doubt that it brings out some ugly sides of ourselves. But I think the personal cost is also really great. Feeding your ambition, when you've done it for long enough, becomes your sole task in many ways. Whatever avenue you can feed your ambition through, you will do so. And the way that it's spoken about is that you don't really have a choice. Like, it's something that you're, you're kind of born with. It's what we would call intrinsic. I also think it comes from how we were raised. And I also think that at times
它被视为一种邪恶。我真的认为我越老，就越理解这一点。野心真的可以把人变成他们本不是的样子。它会导致我们真正忽视他人。我觉得我见过，你也见过。毫无疑问，它会激发出我们自身一些丑陋的一面。但我认为个人代价也非常大。喂养你的野心，当你这样做的时间足够长时，在许多方面就成了你唯一的任务。无论你能通过什么途径喂养你的野心，你都会去做。而且人们谈论它的方式是，你并没有真正的选择。就像，这是你天生就有的东西。这就是我们所说的内在的。我也认为它来自于我们的成长方式。而且我也认为有时
it evolves as a bit of a coping mechanism or a survival strategy against the circumstances of when you were younger. And I see that particularly for myself. As I said, you know, I'm fairly certain historically, like, looking into my own autobiographical memory, like I've always somewhat been this way. But I also think as a kid, I was more aspirational and like driven by curiosity and a love for things. And then that kind of stopped when I got to high school and that's when I became ambitious with a capital A, rather than aspirational with a lowercase A. And the reason I became ambitious is because I believe I saw my ambition and what it could bring me as a way to compensate for some really, really deep insecurities. I really didn't belong. I really didn't feel like I had many friends. I've spoken about
它演变成了一种应对机制或生存策略，以对抗你年轻时的环境。我特别在自己身上看到了这一点。正如我所说，你知道，我很确定从历史上看，比如，回顾我自己的自传式记忆，我一直有点这样。但我也认为小时候，我更有抱负，更受好奇心和对事物的热爱所驱动。然后当我上高中时，那种感觉就停止了，那时我成为了大写的“野心家”，而不是小写的“有抱负的人”。我之所以变得有野心，是因为我相信我把我的野心以及它能带给我的东西，视为一种补偿我内心深处一些非常、非常深刻的不安全感的方式。我真的不属于那里。我真的不觉得我有很多朋友。我之前在播客上谈论过
this before on the podcast, but, you know, I was very lonely. I was also a pretty like, I don't like to say ugly kid, but yeah, I was a little ugly kid and I was a weird kid and I was odd and I was interested in strange things and I was overzealous because I didn't have any friends and I don't think that really helped me socially either because I just really wanted to be part of a group. And what I learned pretty early on was that, you know, if I couldn't be the most liked or the hottest or the smartest, at least I could be the person who works the hardest. And that in itself will bring its own kind of reward. In particular, it will definitely mean that one group of people specifically will like
这一点，但是，你知道，我非常孤独。我当时也是一个相当……我不喜欢说丑陋的孩子，但是的，我是一个有点丑的小孩，我是一个奇怪的孩子，我是一个古怪的孩子，我对奇怪的事情感兴趣，而且我表现得过于热心，因为我没有任何朋友，而且我不认为这在社交上真的帮到了我，因为我只是非常想成为群体的一部分。我早早就学到的是，你知道，如果我不能成为最受欢迎、最火辣或最聪明的人，至少我可以成为那个工作最努力的人。而这本身就会带来它自己的一种回报。特别是，这肯定意味着有一群人会特别喜欢
more, which is adults. Adults will pay more attention to me if I'm ambitious and accomplished. You know, our whole schooling system and the first 18 years of our life really is centralized around a grading system and a ranking system and a system that rewards ambition and kids without actually giving them other ways to function. You know, there are prizes for the most extracurriculars that you can jam into a week and there's prizes for being a straight-A student and for being very academic and I really sunk my teeth into that as a teen. nature. Ambition was like this safe haven for me. You know, if there was nothing else I can control about how others perceive me or how I feel, I can always rely on my ambition. It's also what's going to
我，那就是成年人。如果我有野心且有成就，成年人会更多地关注我。你知道，我们整个学校系统和我们生命的前18年确实是以评分系统、排名系统以及奖励野心的系统为中心的，而没有给孩子们提供其他运作方式。你知道，对于一周内能塞进最多的课外活动有奖励，对于成为全A学生和非常有学术成就的人有奖励，而我作为一个青少年确实沉迷于此。本质上，野心就像是我的避风港。你知道，如果我无法控制别人如何看待我或我的感受，我至少可以依靠我的野心。这也是将要
get me out of this situation that I don't want to be in anymore. You know, I don't, what didn't feel like I really fit in where I grew up and it could have, and it did get me to a good school far, far away. And when I did that, I kind of thought, well, this is where my life can really begin. there's also a deep and unavoidable relationship here between, I would say, ambition, praise, and self-esteem. Psychologists have a term for this. It's called contingent self-worth. And it is a type of self-esteem that is based on the approval of others, specifically for one thing or one domain that you're very good at and that feels particularly important or valuable for you. These two psychologists, and they're amazing, and I really recommend their work. Their names are Jennifer Crocker and Connie Wilf.
带我离开这个我不想再待下去的环境的东西。你知道，我不……我不觉得我真正适合我长大的地方，它确实带我去了很远很远的一所好学校。当我这样做的时候，我有点想，好吧，这就是我生活真正开始的地方。这里也存在着一种深刻且不可避免的关系，我会说，在野心、赞美和自尊之间。心理学家对此有一个术语。它被称为“权变自尊”。这是一种基于他人认可的自尊，特别是针对你非常擅长且对你感觉特别重要或有价值的一件事或一个领域。这两位心理学家，他们很棒，我真的推荐他们的工作。他们的名字是Jennifer Crocker和Connie Wilf。
They're from the University of Michigan. They developed this kind of model in the early 2000s that argues that we all have certain domains where we tend to stake our self-esteem. For some people, that might be their appearance. They really stake how they feel about themselves on how they look. For others, it's romantic approval or being liked. For others, it's competition, it's sports, and for some people, it's just pure ambition. When something goes well in that domain, so you do really well at a sporting event, you get
他们来自密歇根大学。他们在21世纪初开发了这种模型，认为我们都有某些领域，我们倾向于将自尊寄托在这些领域上。对于某些人来说，那可能是他们的外表。他们真的将自己的感受寄托在他们的长相上。对于其他人来说，是浪漫的认可或被喜欢。对于其他人来说，是竞争，是体育，而对于有些人来说，只是纯粹的野心。当那个领域的事情进展顺利时，比如你在体育赛事中表现得非常好，你得到
complimenting on your looks, you get a boyfriend, our self-esteem gets a boost. The more we feel good or rewarded for that specific thing, the more we chase it as a viable way to feel better about ourselves because of the positive reinforcement we are receiving. So if ambition becomes the place where you've decided your worth lives, the abundance of ambition becomes how you feel good about ourselves and the abundance of accomplishment also becomes the way we feel good about ourselves. And our self-esteem becomes very narrow and it becomes very singularly dependent on this one part of who we are and that leaves us very vulnerable. You can see how easily that relationship gets reinforced when you're young. If you study really hard
了对外表的赞美，你交到了男朋友，我们的自尊心就会得到提升。我们对那件特定事情感觉越好或得到的奖励越多，我们就越会追求它，将其作为一种让我们自我感觉更好的可行方式，因为我们正在接受正向强化。所以，如果野心成为了你决定自我价值所在的地方，野心的充裕就成了我们自我感觉良好的方式，成就的充裕也成了我们自我感觉良好的方式。我们的自尊变得非常狭隘，变得非常单一地依赖于我们自我的这一部分，这让我们非常脆弱。你可以看到当你年轻时，这种关系是多么容易被强化。如果你努力学习
and you get an A, you get all this praise from your teachers. Your parents are proud of you. Maybe your name goes on like an honor board. Maybe the other kids who don't particularly notice you socially, sometimes, like suddenly know you as the smart one, the successful one, they ask you for help. Achievement gives you something extremely psychologically powerful and addictive, which is a reliable route to positive attention. I think unlike popularity or unlike attractiveness or even unlike whether somebody wants to be your friend, being ambitious, particularly when you are young, as I said, feels controllable because there are rules and often there is a rubric and there is a hierarchy and there is, you know when
并且你得到了A，你会从老师那里得到所有的赞美。你的父母为你感到骄傲。也许你的名字出现在荣誉榜上。也许那些在社交上并不特别注意你的其他孩子，有时，突然把你视为聪明人、成功者，他们向你寻求帮助。成就给了你某种极其强大且令人上瘾的心理力量，那就是获得积极关注的可靠途径。我认为与受欢迎程度或吸引力，甚至与某人是否想成为你的朋友不同，有野心，特别是当你年轻时，正如我所说，感觉是可控的，因为有规则，通常有评分标准，有等级制度，而且有，你知道什么时候
you're doing well versus when you're not. And that means that it becomes a game that we can play very, very well and very, very easily with enough practice. So this. This is basically the pathway in how we become dependent or addicted to ambition because it's giving us a social and a kind of self-approval that we cannot get elsewhere and that we maybe have never known. Now, there is, of course, a healthy level of ambition. I just don't think I've ever been able to find it because because of what ambition represents for me psychologically and because of what it has represented for me in the past
你做得好，什么时候做得不好。这意味着它变成了一个我们可以通过足够的练习玩得非常好、非常容易的游戏。所以这个。这基本上就是我们如何变得依赖或沉迷于野心的途径，因为它给了我们一种我们在其他地方无法获得的社会和自我认可，而这种认可我们可能从未体验过。当然，有一种健康的野心水平。我只是不认为我曾经能够找到它，因为由于野心在心理上对我所代表的意义，以及因为它在过去
socially, it just became and is still so intertwined with all these other meaningful things and important things that it cannot be isolated away from everything else. So what exactly has changed for me in recent years? Because as grateful as I am to what my ambition has given me, I, like many others, have become very disillusioned. That's what this whole episode is about. And I do think that at some stage, we reach a tipping point. And what that tipping point is is going to be different for everyone. But eventually you get there. So we're going to talk about this. We're going to talk about what's kind of driven me to question my ambition and maybe want to break from it in just a second. So stay with us.
在社交上对我所代表的意义，它已经变得并且仍然与所有这些其他有意义和重要的事情交织在一起，以至于它无法与所有其他事物隔离开来。那么近年来对我来说到底发生了什么变化呢？因为尽管我很感激我的野心给了我什么，但我像许多其他人一样，变得非常幻灭。这就是这一整期节目的内容。我确实认为在某个阶段，我们达到了一个临界点。而这个临界点对每个人来说都是不同的。但最终你会到达那里。所以我们要谈谈这个。我们将在片刻之后谈谈是什么驱动我质疑我的野心，并可能想要从中解脱出来。所以请留下来。
There's no shortcut for saving time, but saving money is simple. Just combine your car and home insurance with Bel Air Direct and save. Get a quote at bellair direct.com. So I think the question for the second half of this episode is when does ambition start to become a curse after so many years of it kind of being seen as an ally? The tipping point for a lot people, it's just burnout. Ambition is very all-consuming. And let's be real, it really doesn't care about if you're balanced. It really doesn't care about if you're fulfilled or if you have friends or if you have time for your family. Everything else in your life is demoted and it's seen as unimportant. Ambition really only operates on one metric and one dimension, which is success and recognition
节省时间没有捷径，但省钱很简单。只需将您的汽车和房屋保险与Bel Air Direct合并即可省钱。请访问belairdirect.com获取报价。所以我认为这一期节目后半部分的问题是，在多年来它一直被视为盟友之后，野心何时开始成为一种诅咒？对许多人来说，临界点就是倦怠。野心是非常消耗人的。说实话，它真的不在乎你是否平衡。它真的不在乎你是否满足，或者你是否有朋友，或者你是否有时间陪伴家人。你生活中的其他一切都被降级，被视为不重要。野心真的只在一个指标和一个维度上运作，那就是成功和认可
and pride and as much of those things as we can get. The thing is that those emotional states and those feelings have a very short psychological shelf life. What I mean by that is that a feeling of pride and a feeling of like, okay, I'm doing okay here and I feel happy and I feel like I've really done something good, that can only last anywhere from a few weeks to a few hours because our ambition is will inevitably be hungry again. It will inevitably want more. For example, you know, and I've seen this in my own life, a big thing that I've been loving recently is sub-sacac. and writing on substack. And for a while, I kind of just did it with no expectations. And I just kind of did it because I really loved it. And I felt like it was this very serene and cozy corner of the internet. And it's still very much it is, if I'm being honest. But then I started to get subscribers and I started to get followers. And that was it. That was it.
以及自豪感，以及我们能从中获得尽可能多的这些东西。问题是，那些情绪状态和感受的心理保质期非常短。我的意思是，一种自豪感和一种“好吧，我在这里做得不错，我感到快乐，我觉得我真的做了一些好事”的感觉，只能持续几周到几个小时，因为我们的野心不可避免地会再次饥饿。它不可避免地想要更多。例如，你知道，我在自己的生活中也看到了这一点，我最近非常喜欢的一件大事是Substack。以及在Substack上写作。有一段时间，我只是没有任何期望地去做。我只是因为真的很喜欢它而去做。我觉得这是互联网上一个非常宁静和舒适的角落。如果我诚实的话，它现在仍然非常是这样。但后来我开始有了订阅者，我开始有了粉丝。就是这样。就是这样。
That was like, that's all. You know, my ambitious mind was kind of like, took that, saw that and was like, okay, well, this is our terrain now. We're going to take over from here. And it suddenly made me very obsessive. And it meant that it wasn't fun anymore. And I reached like 400,000 subscribers a couple of weeks back. And that's an insane number of people. And it was this amazing feeling for a second of like, wow, I've worked really hard at this. I feel really connected to this community. I feel a sense of accomplishment. That lasted literally, I would say, 48 hours before I was like preoccupied with the next milestone and preoccupied with this and that, this is the curse of ambition. Like, that's not fun. It is not fun to feel that way. But ambition tells you that it doesn't need to be fun. The process
就是那样。你知道，我那充满野心的头脑有点像，接受了那个，看到了那个，然后说，好吧，现在这是我们的领地了。我们要从这里接管。它突然让我变得非常强迫。这意味着它不再有趣了。几周前我达到了40万订阅者。这是一个疯狂的人数。有一瞬间，这是一种令人惊叹的感觉，比如，哇，我为此付出了很多努力。我感到与这个社区紧密相连。我有一种成就感。那持续了，我可以说，字面上48小时，然后我就开始全神贯注于下一个里程碑，全神贯注于这个和那个，这就是野心的诅咒。就像，那并不有趣。那种感觉并不有趣。但野心告诉你，它不需要有趣。过程
doesn't need to be fun because the outcomes it produces will be worth it. And it doesn't tell you the kind of fine print, which is that the outcome is only ever going to feel good for a second compared to the time you spent to get that outcome. You may have have heard of another psychology term for this, pretty well known, the hedonic treadmill. And the hedonic treadmill or hedonic adaptation, as it's also known, is our tendency and our ability to adapt to changes in our circumstances, particularly improvements. The thing that once seemed extraordinary and amazing and life-changing eventually becomes very normal. And our expectations kind of rise alongside that. There has been so much research on ambition that is
不需要有趣，因为它产生的成果将是值得的。而且它没有告诉你那种细则，那就是与你为获得该成果所花费的时间相比，成果只会让你感觉好一秒钟。你可能听说过另一个心理学术语，非常有名，享乐适应。享乐适应，也称为享乐跑步机，是我们适应环境变化，特别是改善的倾向和能力。曾经看起来非凡、令人惊叹和改变生活的事情最终变得非常正常。我们的期望也随之上升。关于野心已经有了很多研究，
found that people who are highly ambitious, achieving a goal for them does still produce positive emotions, but those emotional benefits and positive emotions are not necessarily as permanent as they are for others, especially if you are somebody who is pursuing achievement and pursuing success from a place of longing or lacking or emptiness. They only serve one psychological purpose, which is to not make you feel bad about yourself. I think I guess what I just realized was that none of this was making me happy anymore, but also I do all this stuff, I work so hard, I sacrifice, and then what? A lot of the time, our ambition actually doesn't even have a payout anyways. And I was actually talking to a listener about this the other day who wrote in. And she was
发现那些非常有野心的人，实现目标对他们来说确实会产生积极情绪，但这些情感益处和积极情绪并不一定像对其他人那样持久，特别是如果你是一个从渴望、缺乏或空虚的角度追求成就和成功的人。它们只服务于一个心理目的，那就是不让你对自己感觉糟糕。我想我猜我刚刚意识到的是，这一切都不再让我快乐了，但我也做了所有这些事情，我工作得如此努力，我牺牲，然后呢？很多时候，我们的野心实际上甚至没有任何回报。我前几天还在和一个听众谈论这件事，她写信给我。她在
talking about this in the context of looking for work, and she's just graduating uni, and she's looking for a a bad job. And what she basically said was that she spent her whole life being straight-a-student, amazing student, convinced that working hard, giving up weekends, doing everything extra was a secret to a stable, happy life. And now she's looking for a job and she can't get one. And she doesn't get any callbacks and she doesn't get any bites. And she's like, I've done everything right. I'm so ambitious. And the ambition that promised so much has really just left me feeling awfully disappointed. And what she essentially was realizing was like, I could have spent all that time actually enjoying myself. And I didn't because I was sold this kind of lie. There was this weird
谈论在找工作的背景下谈论这一点，她刚从大学毕业，正在找一份糟糕的工作。她基本上说的是，她一生都是全A学生，出色的学生，确信努力工作、放弃周末、做所有额外的事情是稳定、幸福生活的秘诀。现在她在找工作，却找不到。她没有得到任何回电，也没有得到任何回应。她说，我做的一切都是对的。我太有野心了。而那个承诺了那么多的野心，真的只是让我感到非常失望。她本质上意识到的是，我本可以把所有那些时间真正用来享受自己。但我没有，因为我被兜售了这种谎言。有一种奇怪的
sense where we feel like we need to work hard to secure a good future so that in 25, 30 years, we won't have to worry about money and we can enjoy ourselves and that is a very important thing. But we could have been enjoying ourselves the whole time rather than just at the end if we'd had a gentle a form of ambition. This relates to something I said just before. What does ambition really give us other than simply more ambition? You know, there's a strange metaphor. There's probably like a riddle in this, really, which is, I don't know, what could the riddle be? Like, what's something that gets hungry or the more you feed it? That is ambition. That is our sense of accomplishment. The more you give it, the more at once. There is a bottomless pit. For me, though, I personally think my turning point
感觉，我们觉得我们需要努力工作以确保一个美好的未来，这样在25、30年后，我们就不用担心钱，可以享受自己，那是一件非常重要的事情。但如果我们有一种更温和的野心，我们本可以在整个过程中一直享受自己，而不是只在最后。这与我刚才说的一点有关。除了仅仅是更多的野心，野心还能给我们什么？你知道，有一个奇怪的隐喻。这可能是一个谜语，真的，那就是，我不知道，谜语可能是什么？比如，有什么东西是越喂越饿的？那就是野心。那就是我们的成就感。你给它的越多，它想要的就越多。有一个无底洞。不过对我来说，我个人认为我的转折点
was when I realized ambition didn't actually make me a happy or well-rounded person. Specifically, what was the trigger for me was when I was on vacation when I was on holiday. And I was in the south of France last week with a big group of my friends and these are like my best friends. And we've all chipped in for this beautiful Airbnb and we're cooking fresh fish and we're going to the beach and we're having wine and we're eating, we're playing games. And I could genuinely not relax. I could not be in the present moment if I had not done at least a couple hours of work that day.
是我意识到野心并没有真正让我成为一个快乐或全面发展的人。具体来说，触发我的是我上周度假的时候。我上周在法国南部，和一大群朋友在一起，他们就像我最好的朋友。我们都凑钱租了这个漂亮的Airbnb，我们正在做新鲜的鱼，我们去海滩，我们喝着酒，我们吃着东西，我们玩游戏。但我真的无法放松。如果我那天没有做至少几个小时的工作，我就无法活在当下。
Like I couldn't do it. And on one of the days, everyone went on this ferry to this island and I stayed home and I worked and I didn't need to. Like I could have taken my meeting and go on and join them later. But it was this compulsion. Like it was a compulsion. I was like, I have to earn my enjoyment and I haven't done enough work to relax yet. I just think that is like so many other forms of disordered thinking, you know, believing that we have to earn calories or earn certain foods, believing that we have to earn
就像我做不到。有一天，大家坐渡轮去了那个岛，我留下来工作，我不需要这样做。就像我可以参加完会议再去加入他们。但这是一种强迫。就像这是一种强迫。我想，我必须赚取我的享受，而且我还没有做足够的工作来放松。我只是认为这就像许多其他形式的紊乱思维一样，你知道，相信我们必须赚取卡路里或赚取某些食物，相信我们必须通过锻炼来赚取
rest through exercise, believing that we have to earn love. It's so similar. It is believing that I need to earn permission from my ambition to actually enjoy my life. And I was just kind of like How horrible is that? And you know what? Everything that I did that day, like it could have waited. None of it was urgent. Most of it was also pretty unimportant. All of it was.
休息，相信我们必须赚取爱。这太相似了。这就是相信我需要从我的野心中获得许可才能真正享受我的生活。我当时只是有点，那有多可怕？你知道吗？我那天做的一切，它本可以等待。没有什么是紧急的。大部分也相当不重要。全部都是。
But I just felt I felt like I needed to do it so that I could relax and not feel guilty. And if I just relaxed, I would have felt lazy and I wouldn't have been able to enjoy myself. So to kind of summarize this feeling, I think it's really that my ambition promises me my dream. life whilst my real life kind of passes me by. And that is why I have a problem with it. And this is the curse of ambition. It becomes such a core part of your identity, my identity, our identity, that you have to keep living it out and serving it even when it no longer serves you because it feels like it is your friend. And I read this really great article from the sub-sec is star-burned and it's titled, Who Am I Without My Ambition? And the author, she says,
但我只是觉得，我觉得我需要做它，这样我才能放松，不会感到内疚。如果我只是放松，我会感到懒惰，我将无法享受自己。所以为了总结这种感觉，我认为这确实是我的野心向我承诺了我的梦想生活，而我的真实生活却从我身边溜走了。这就是为什么我对它有意见。这就是野心的诅咒。它成为了你身份、我的身份、我们身份的核心部分，以至于你必须继续活出它并服务于它，即使它不再为你服务，因为它感觉就像它是你的朋友。我读了这篇来自Substack的非常棒的文章，它叫《没有野心我是谁？》，作者说，
something which I think really resonates, which is that ambition is very spiky and it convinces you that you cannot live without it. And in that way, it's like a toxic relationship. It really is. It's amazing when it's really good, but the good doesn't last very long. And then it's awful the rest of the time. But we're convinced that we need it. And obviously I'm not trying to compare the two, but I think that it's, it's an important metaphor to understand your relationship with ambition differently rather than just as a good thing. So if you've reached, a similar point to me of questioning who am I beyond my ambition, who am I beyond somebody that's able to work hard, what do we do with this? How do we form a healthier relationship with it when
一些我认为真正引起共鸣的话，那就是野心是非常尖锐的，它让你相信没有它你就无法生活。从这个意义上说，它就像一段有毒的关系。确实如此。它在非常好的时候很棒，但好的时候持续不了多久。然后剩下的时间都很糟糕。但我们确信我们需要它。显然我不是想比较这两者，但我认为这是一个重要的隐喻，可以让你以不同的方式理解你与野心的关系，而不是仅仅把它当作一件好事。所以如果你已经达到了和我一样的质疑“除了野心之外我是谁”的临界点，我们该怎么处理这个？当我们
it's kind of all we've ever known? I think the most critical thing that we can do for ourselves is to see who we are and how much we have to offer as more than just our productivity and our work ethic. We are kind of valuing ourselves as we would a machine. But we are a person, We are a living, breathing creature who brings so much more value than just input and output. And you cannot have a healthier relationship with ambition if you do not acknowledge that. One of the concepts I find really useful here is called self-complexity. This is a concept I learned from the researcher, Patricia Linville from Duke University. And she basically describes how we have to be able to acknowledge the different dimensions that make up our sense of self.
只知道这些时，我们如何与它形成更健康的关系？我认为我们能为自己做的最关键的事情，就是将我们是谁以及我们能提供多少东西，视为不仅仅是我们的产出和职业道德。我们有点像对待机器一样评估自己。但我们是一个人，我们是一个活生生的、呼吸的生物，带来的价值远不止输入和输出。如果你不承认这一点，你就无法与野心建立更健康的关系。我在这里发现非常有用的概念之一叫做“自我复杂性”。这是我从杜克大学的研究员Patricia Linville那里学到的概念。她基本上描述了我们必须能够承认构成我们自我感的不同维度。
and you cannot be happy if you don't hold all those versions as equally important and equally deserving of respect. So you might be a lawyer, you might be a straight-day student, you might be a designer or a business owner, but you are also a friend and a sibling and a partner, and you are also somebody who was funny and curious and creative and adventurous and you're really good at remembering birthdays and you're obsessed with a particular movie and you are somebody who makes others feel very, very comfortable, just because those parts of you have less productive value, like, that doesn't mean that they are meaningless. Like, they are kind of the whole point. And research on self-complexity by that same researcher really shows that there are psychological benefits to being able to respect
而且如果你不把所有这些版本视为同样重要且同样值得尊重，你就无法快乐。所以你可能是一名律师，你可能是一名全A学生，你可能是一名设计师或企业主，但你也是一个朋友、一个兄弟姐妹和一个伴侣，你也是一个有趣、好奇、有创造力、爱冒险的人，你非常擅长记住生日，你沉迷于某部特定的电影，你是一个让别人感到非常、非常舒服的人，仅仅因为你身上的这些部分产出价值较低，那并不意味着它们毫无意义。它们才是重点所在。而同一位研究员关于自我复杂性的研究确实表明，能够尊重
the parts of you that may not necessarily be traditionally useful, but make you feel like yourself. because when one area of your life takes a hit, and it will, it doesn't necessarily have to threaten our entire sense of who we are. So if your whole identity is, I am somebody who is successful, I am somebody who is ambitious, a professional failure is not just a professional failure, it is a full-blown identity crisis because there is nothing else to rest your identity on. But if you are successful but also a good friend and kind and generous and animals love you, like a professional issue, like you can step out of that role. So I think if you want to know who you are without your ambition, list it out, you know, hi, my name is Gemma and I'm, I'm ambitious and I'm a hard
你身上那些未必传统上有用，但让你感觉像你自己的部分，是有心理益处的。因为当你生活中的一个领域受到打击时，而且它一定会受到打击，它不一定非要威胁到我们对自我的整个认知。所以如果你的整个身份是，我是一个成功的人，我是一个有野心的人，职业失败不仅仅是职业失败，它是一场全面的身份危机，因为没有其他东西可以寄托你的身份。但如果你成功，同时也是一个好朋友，善良且慷慨，而且动物喜欢你，那么职业问题，你可以走出那个角色。所以我认为如果你想知道没有野心你是谁，列出来，你知道，嗨，我的名字是Gemma，我很有野心，我是一个努力
worker. But here is like something more interesting about me, which is that I host really great dinner parties. And I am, I've read 20 books this year and I always call my long distance best friends. I'm very good at that. And if no one noticed, I would still be interested in psychology and I'd still be interested in research and I would still be interested in the world and I think I would still be a good person. And those are all things that I am without my ambition. I also believe, secondly to this, that we have to stop thinking about ambition as this thing that will expire or go off if we don't use all of it right now. That is a frame of mind that I find myself in all the time. If I don't keep up with my ambition and if I don't constantly stretch it and test it,
工作的人。但这里有一些关于我更有趣的事情，那就是我举办非常棒的晚宴。而且我今年读了20本书，我总是给我的异地最好的朋友打电话。我非常擅长这一点。如果没人注意到，我仍然会对心理学感兴趣，我仍然会对研究感兴趣，我仍然会对世界感兴趣，我想我仍然会是一个好人。而这些都是我在没有野心的情况下所拥有的东西。我还要相信，其次，我们必须停止认为野心是那种如果我们现在不全部使用它就会过期或失效的东西。那是我一直处于的那种心态。如果我不跟上我的野心，如果我不不断地伸展它和测试它，
like I'm going to forget how to be ambitious. And so when I finally eventually stumble on something I really want to be ambitious about, I'm not going to be able to do it. I won't be able to make it work. You know, what if I suddenly become lazy? Is that a possibility? That's like the big fear with giving up our ambition. This is such a deep cognitive fallacy.
就像我会忘记如何有野心一样。所以当我最终偶然发现我真正想有野心的事情时，我将无法做到。我将无法让它成功。你知道，如果我突然变得懒惰了怎么办？那是一种可能性吗？这就是放弃我们的野心带来的巨大恐惧。这是一种非常深刻的认知谬误。
And it's the same fallacy that keeps us hooked or dependent on so many things. because it treats ambition as this physical resource rather than as this intrinsic part of who you are. You know, as we know from the literature that we've already covered, ambition is part of our personality. We are often very much born with it, with a percentage of it. It's just, it's inbuilt to your temperament. And the intrinsic nature here is, I think, both the curse and part of the solution, because you cannot unlearn something completely that is part of who you are, the same way that you
而且这与让我们沉迷或依赖于许多事物的谬误是一样的。因为它把野心视为一种物理资源，而不是你身上内在的一部分。你知道，正如我们从我们已经涵盖的文献中所知，野心是我们人格的一部分。我们通常在很大程度上是天生就带着它的，带着一定比例的它。它只是，它内置在你的气质中。而这里的内在本质，我认为，既是诅咒，也是解决方案的一部分，因为你无法完全忘记你身上的一部分，就像你
cannot unlearn other parts of who you are, like your kindness or your sensitivity or your sense of justice. These things don't go bad. They don't expire from lack of use. They just can and will sit below the surface for a little while until you need them and then you can call on them. And what we're also forgetting is that when we do need them for something really, really important, and we do really want to call on our ambition as this hidden well of reserves we have, we'll probably have more motivation and most importantly more time to actually execute our vision because we're not kind of tied up and having all these other things and activities that our ambition required us to do in order to feed it and keep it satiated.
无法忘记你身上其他部分一样，比如你的善良、你的敏感或你的正义感。这些东西不会变坏。它们不会因为缺乏使用而过期。它们只是可以并且会在表面下停留一会儿，直到你需要它们，然后你就可以调用它们。而且我们还忘记了，当我们确实需要它们来做一些非常、非常重要的事情，并且我们确实想把我们的野心作为我们拥有的隐藏储备库来调用时，我们可能会有更多的动力，最重要的是有更多的时间来真正执行我们的愿景，因为我们没有被所有这些野心要求我们做以喂养它并保持它满足的其他事情和活动所束缚。
You know, this idea that we may forget our ambition is basically just catastrophizing. It's all or nothing thinking that is very, very relevant and severe in our 20s. In our 20s, I'll be the first to admit, like, I don't know who I am yet. I'm sure you don't really know who you are. And so we imagine that there are really only some very binary versions of us. There's only two possible versions of ourselves. Either I am the relentlessly ambitious person who is constantly achieving, or I am the lazy person who is completely given up.
你知道，这种我们可能会忘记我们的野心的想法基本上只是灾难化。这是在我们的二十多岁时非常、非常相关且严重的非黑即白思维。在我们的二十多岁时，我会第一个承认，比如，我还不知道我是谁。我相信你也不知道你真正是谁。所以我们想象只有一些非常二元的版本。我们只有两个可能的版本。要么我是那个不断取得成就的无情野心家，要么我是那个完全放弃的懒惰的人。
There is no middle ground. That's what our brain tells us. And that's crazy. No one is ever just one thing. We are so much more nuanced than that. And I think just like nature, we have our seasons. We have our seasons where we work really hard and we blossom and we have a lot of harvest or output. You equally require the winters of life and you require seasons of rest and hibernation that allow for the prosperous seasons.
没有中间地带。这就是我们的大脑告诉我们的。这太疯狂了。没有人永远只是某一种东西。我们比那要微妙得多。而且我认为就像大自然一样，我们有我们的季节。我们有我们努力工作、开花结果并有大量收获或产出的季节。你也同样需要生活的冬天，你需要休息和冬眠的季节，这为繁荣的季节提供了可能。
Everything has to occur in this balance. And by trying to push ambition constantly, you disrupt the natural balance of being. I think the final solution for the ambition problem, crucially, is also just to be more clear about why you want something to begin with and what you would be giving up by pursuing that thing right now. Essentially, it's about interrogating if you are feeding the ambition beast because the ambition beast is hungry or you are actually feeding yourself and your soul. Specific questions to ask yourself, would you still want this thing if no one else was around? is getting this thing actually going to make you happy?
一切都必须在这种平衡中发生。通过不断地推动野心，你破坏了存在的自然平衡。我认为野心问题的最终解决方案，至关重要的是，也要更清楚你为什么从一开始就想要某样东西，以及你现在追求那件事会放弃什么。本质上，这是关于审视你是在喂养野心野兽，因为野心野兽饿了，还是你实际上是在喂养你自己和你的灵魂。问自己具体的问题，如果周围没有其他人，你还会想要这个东西吗？得到这个东西真的会让你快乐吗？
Is the desire to achieve this sitting in for some other fundamental need? Like the need to feel like you matter or the need to feel like you're important. Again, coming back to this thing, is this actually going to make me happy? You only have so much time. That's part of the fear around giving up ambition. But you need to decide whether you're going to spend that ambition on small vanity projects or little things or you're going to save it. you're going to store it up for something really, really, really special to use all your
实现这个的欲望是否在填补其他某种基本需求？比如想要感到你有价值或想要感到你很重要的需求。再次回到这一点，这真的会让我快乐吗？你的时间只有那么多。这就是围绕放弃野心的恐惧的一部分。但你需要决定你是要把那份野心花在小的虚荣项目或小事情上，还是你要保存它。你要把它储存起来，用于一些非常、非常、非常特别的事情，以使用你所有的
ambition on it. It's going to feel really purposeful rather than just just something to kind of keep the demons away. I think as ambitious people, we need to become much better at thinking about opportunity cost. Every kind of yes to one version of your life is inevitably a no to another. So if you decide, I don't know, if you decide you want to build the biggest company in the world or in your industry, and you want to become the best researcher in your field or at your university and you want to work every weekend for the next 10 years, maybe that is genuinely worth it to you and you have found what you really care about. But you should at least acknowledge what you are exchanging for it, which is perhaps more meaningful, slower experiences
怀揣抱负。这会让你感觉非常有目标感，而不是仅仅为了驱散内心的魔障。我认为作为有抱负的人，我们需要更深入地思考机会成本。对生活的一种选择，必然意味着对另一种选择的放弃。所以，如果你决定，我不知道，如果你决定要建立世界上或你所在行业中最大的公司，你想成为你领域或大学里最优秀的研究员，并且你愿意在未来十年里的每个周末都工作，也许这对你来说确实值得，你也找到了你真正关心的东西。但你至少应该承认你为此付出的代价，那可能是一些更有意义、更缓慢的体验。
that are worth a lot more. Ambition has this tendency to make a lot of, its rewards extremely visible and its costs extremely invisible. It's very easy to be like, this person is successful because they make all this money and they have this award and they have this number of followers. It is much harder to point to the afternoon that they missed with their friends that did not happen. It's much harder to point to the cost to their mental health of constantly thinking, am I doing enough? Am I reaching my potential? I should be doing more. I could always be doing more, am I a failure? Like, we don't see that cost.
那些价值远高于此的体验。抱负有一种倾向，就是让它的回报变得极其显眼，而让它的代价变得极其隐蔽。人们很容易说，这个人很成功，因为他们赚了很多钱，获得了这个奖项，拥有这么多粉丝。但要指出他们错过的与朋友相处的下午，或者那些从未发生的时光，就难得多了。要指出他们因不断思考“我做得够了吗？我发挥出潜力了吗？我应该做得更多。我总能做得更多，我是个失败者吗？”而对心理健康造成的损害，也难得多。我们看不到这些代价。
And it's not a nice feeling at all to never be happy with what you have. And I think it's a reality that endless ambition creates, which is dissatisfaction at times. You know, and I think it's worth questioning, why do I even need to be the best? Why do I even need these accomplishments or things if the only thing it gets me is, again, a deeper sense that I'm not doing enough and just a bar that keeps being raised? I never stopped to examine that is happiness or satisfaction ever even on the on the on the cards. I guess I don't really know. I don't really know.
而且，对所拥有的东西永远不感到满足，这种感觉一点也不好。我认为这是无止境的抱负所带来的现实，即有时会感到不满。你知道，我认为值得质疑的是，为什么我非得成为最优秀的？如果我所获得的一切，仅仅是让我更深刻地感到自己做得不够，以及那个不断被提高的标准，那么我为什么还需要这些成就或东西呢？我从未停下来审视过，幸福或满足感是否真的在考虑范围内。我想我真的不知道。我真的不知道。
I just know that part of that that there is a part of me that is hopefully trying to work on being better with my ambition. And I definitely don't want to be 30 or 40 and still thinking this way. And I don't want to be 30 or 40 and still bringing my laptop on every holiday so that I can earn my time off. And I don't want to be 30 or 40 and feeling like if I don't achieve X, in this amount of time it is all over. I don't know. Maybe that's just something that time kind of helps with,
我只知道，我内心有一部分正希望能努力改善我的抱负观。我绝对不想到了30岁或40岁时还这样想。我不想到了30岁或40岁时，每次度假还要带着笔记本电脑，好让自己能“赚取”休息时间。我也不想到了30岁或40岁时，还觉得如果我在这个时间内没有实现某个目标，一切就都完了。我不知道。也许这只是时间能有所帮助的事情，
but it's something I'm struggling with and something that I know a lot of you are and hopefully just being able to relate to this and us being able to tear apart the narrative and the myths that ambition sells us is useful and helpful because it's definitely been helpful to me. So I think that's all I have for today. I think that's, I feel better.
但这确实是我正在挣扎的事情，也是我知道你们很多人正在经历的事情。希望能够产生共鸣，并且我们能够拆解抱负向我们兜售的叙事和神话，是有用且有帮助的，因为它对我来说确实很有帮助。所以我想今天就讲到这里。我想，我感觉好多了。
That's all my thoughts. summarized and wrapped up and delivered to you in this neat tiny episode. So I hope that you can relate to this episode in some way. It's made you feel better. If you have, you know, made it this far. Thank you for listening. Feel free to leave a little comment down below if you're listening on Spotify. Make sure that you leave a five-star review or share this episode with a friend.
这就是我所有的想法。总结、归纳并在这期简洁的小节目中呈现给你们。所以我希望你们能以某种方式与这期节目产生共鸣。它让你们感觉好了一些。如果你已经听到了这里，谢谢你的收听。如果你是在Spotify上收听，欢迎在下方留下评论。请务必留下五星好评，或者把这期节目分享给朋友。
If you think that it might help them as well, fellow former high achievers, eldest daughters, straight-A students, I feel like we can all unite around this topic. There's heaps more, as I said, I'm really enjoying substack, and it's actually the thing I'm trying to focus on just enjoying for the sake of it more. So if you want to join me over there, there'll be a link in the description alongside our Instagram, where you can watch this episode and many others just like it on Netflix. There's just always, there's always some goodies down there. But again, thank you for listening.
如果你认为这也能帮助到他们的话。各位曾经的优等生、长女们、全A学生们，我觉得我们可以在这个话题上团结起来。正如我所说，还有很多内容，我真的很享受Substack，这实际上是我正努力尝试去享受、去纯粹体验的事情。所以如果你想加入我，描述栏里会有链接，还有我们的Instagram，你可以在那里观看这期节目以及许多类似的内容。下方总是有一些好东西。但再次感谢你们的收听。
Until next time, be safe, be kind, be gentle to yourself. We will talk very, very soon. This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
下次见，注意安全，保持善良，善待自己。我们很快就会再聊。这是一档I-Heart播客。保证由人类制作。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。